[Music]
hi everybody welcome to the data science
hangout i'm sure we'll have quite a few
people joining in
and in the next few minutes here too but
if you're joining for the first time
it's great to meet you i'm rachel
if this is your first hangout
this is an open space for the whole data
science community to connect and
chat about data science leadership
questions you're facing and what's
really going on in the world of data
science
these sessions are recorded and shared
to youtube as well as the rstudio data
science hangout site so you can always
go back and re-watch to find helpful
resources or share with others
i'll say this up front because i always
forget this we also have a linkedin
group for the hangout too so if you ever
want to continue a certain discussion or
see a brief summary of a topic brought
up each week
you can join that group
i'll share it in just a second so i
don't
so i don't
pause here but um we always want to
create spaces where everybody can
participate and we can hear from
everyone so there's three ways you can
ask questions today
you can jump in by raising your hand on
zoom and i'll just call on you
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and feel free to just put a little star
next to it if you want me to read it out
loud instead
or i can call on you to introduce
yourself and ask
but we also have a slido link that
hannah will share in just a second here
in the chat where you can ask questions
anonymously too
so this is all for you and all the
questions are audience-led so just like
to reiterate we love to hear from
everyone no matter your level of
experience or
area of work
but today i'm so happy to be joined by
my co-host travis gerk travis's director
of data science at the prostate cancer
clinical trials consortium
that's a hard one to say
but um travis i'd love to turn it over
to you and have you just introduce
yourself and maybe share a little bit
about the work that you do
yeah sure um so hi i'm travis thanks so
much for having me this is really great
um i've been on a couple hangouts and
they're always fun
uh so right as rachel said i'm director
of data science at the prostate cancer
clinical trials consortium which yes it
is a mouthful and the acronym might be
even more tricky pcctc um try saying
that five times fast but uh whatever the
case maybe we're sort of we're a cro so
a clinical research organization
meaning that we facilitate the work of
clinical trials from end to end
for often pharmaceutical sponsors or
sometimes so-called independent
investigator initiated trials
which will be maybe
physician scientists who've initiated a
trial at their at their site um at their
hospital
and we have a
we're sort of a boutique cro in the
sense that we mostly do prostate cancer
oncology work
so right now we're running about a
quarter of all early phase clinical
trials and late stage prostate cancer in
the u.s and we have a few global studies
as well so
it's good um we we do uh as i said we
kind of collect all the data at the
sites we help the sites launch the trial
and then once the data starts rolling in
that's when the data science team takes
over we do a lot of counting a lot of
tabling make figures we use our markdown
um something you know that we're excited
to do is move the clinical trials
reporting space more towards our python
other open source technologies over
uh traditionally a licensed dominated
space such as sas and things like that
um of course we're not we're not the
only kind of thought leaders in the
space there's a lot of great work from
gsk roche and
taurus and others that we we keep tabs
on and we love to learn from you all as
we go
awesome thank you and so i know a lot of
people have commented in the chat
already about um your amazing
background and wanting to know where are
you right now
i i just think the guest is you're
coming glacier national fight like i
i've
i feel like i've become bigfoot these
days there's someone on twitter recently
said did i just have a travis gerke
sighting um
this no i'm not in glacier anymore we're
we're now in washington state
um i'm on a river called the nisqually
which is just outside of olympia um near
seattle
awesome so i guess
transition no i'm just gonna say i feel
like that's a great transition into i
hinted that we would chat a little bit
about very remote
work um i would love to learn a little
bit more about your travels and working
remotely
yeah this is something kind of wild that
we did so um my wife and we have two
kids they're seven and eight and a dog
um we used to live in florida and then
we were never fans of the heat and then
for that and
reasons uh we just said let's leave so
so we sold our home and we bought an rv
in a truck and sold most of our stuff
and now we live full-time in an rv and
um i just do data science from from
wherever we are um lately it's been on
the pacific northwest but
it's great um i'm happy to answer any
odd questions you might have about that
i
100 out of 10 recommend it uh if anyone
has the urge to just
get up and move um it's it's very
pandemic friendly we don't see many
people often um although we want to go
to the city we can we went to seattle
yesterday was fun so
um yeah that's one of the good things
about data science it's pretty flexible
you can do from anywhere really
that's amazing i see libby you asked a
question somewhere a bit earlier about
internet do you want to jump in
yeah
hey travis and i are talking about this
one
linked in a little bit i was like you're
gonna spill all your secrets about how
you have internet and all these places
right because i my husband and i both
work remotely and we both feel like the
internet is like a utility for us now
it's like a boundary to
to working um
so i'd love to know more about like how
you stay connected all over the place
and if you have any absolutely trouble
yeah no um i've i've shockingly actually
not had any trouble yet i geeked out on
this big time before we did this because
you're right um without internet it
can't do much um in terms of of work but
uh even in the remotest places we've
been i think big bend in texas we were
the furthest from
civilization i was still able to
maintain zoom meetings um much to my
surprise actually you know i prepped for
a little bit um on a week like that
where i'm pretty remote i make sure to
set up
um a lot of kind of maybe it's a
learning week or you know kind of heads
down work it's actually kind of good it
gives you a little bit of space from
the the usual grind of just zoom to zoom
um but even in that case it wasn't
necessary so um today i'm using this hot
spot so these hot spots um this one's
the 5g neg here um i can always share
details about these things but um this
one so i have redundant um phone plans
for this sort of thing um this one today
i'm on a tnt uh this this hotspot also
runs a t-mobile but i but i have um i
also have verizon plans for
um it just depends it depends where we
are what kind of what kind of service is
going to give us the best but i've
actually never had a challenge streaming
videos
zoom things like that something else
that's helpful if you get a hot spot
these little boosters and this is like
20 on amazon um
they can be tremendously helpful
they kind of like funnel the signal and
into your into your hotspot a little bit
better there's one and if you want to
really geek out on this like i did the
the best resources uh website called rv
mobileinternet.com
um and you can check that out these days
i think if i even had like a proper home
i might consider doing this instead of
proper
like cable or whatever internet um
because the price is pretty similar and
often i have better signal much my
amusement than
my
kind of at-home colleagues um that i'm
zooming with so yeah it works well um
it's fun
did that answer your ques i i could
really you can tell i can talk about
that for days but uh yeah
it did thank you so much i really
appreciate it i'm gonna pass some of
this along to my sister my sister lived
in a van her and her husband lived in
van for about 10 years
and they've just recently settled down
into a tiny home but they are still
really far from everything so it's been
a little bit of a struggle
very cool
i love raja's comment in the chat that
this is exactly the kind of conversation
i've been craving
um
aaron i see you asked a question too do
you want to jump in
hi yeah this is aaron um
i was just wondering because i've tried
to work
in places where there's lots of sunlight
before and i find it's really hard to
even if the sun isn't shining directly
on you if there is any sun on touching
anything in the background behind you
it's hard to keep the glare off the
screen so i was wondering if you just
had
tips for us
i i wish i had a brilliant thing to
suggest and maybe others will um for
today i kind of just wandered around
until i found a shady spot so i'm kind
of like in the shade and then
and i'm actually letting just my macbook
pro do all the work i'm even using the
the onboard camera i mean i do have
i do have like a stream cam that
sometimes i use but most times i find
this is okay um i'm sorry if it's a
disappointing answer
no thank you
yep i'm wishing i was wandering around
outside like looking for nice places
that i should just take the hang out
outside next time
i think um mike that you asked a
question in the chat you want to jump in
hi thanks thanks for discussing this
travis i hope you don't mind that we're
talking about you know your your work
lifestyle rather than good data science
or anything complicated it's a hangout
for um
i i work remote from the most of my team
uh they're predominantly us-based
um and classic uh situation here in the
in the uk today is a bank a public
holiday because of the queen's platinum
jubilee um
last monday was a us public holiday
so you know my colleagues are hitting me
up on my public holiday but i wasn't
allowed to hit them up on their public
holiday but
when you're out and about how do your
colleagues kind of
um
how do you how do you balance up you
know time at work versus you know time i
can be available for conversations and
how do you have those conversations with
colleagues to say look you know i'm
going to be busy or or traveling between
here and here
you know so
don't expect an answer in that time
period
yeah it's such a great question and it
is always i mean it's something that one
has to be very intentional about and
just communicate broadly i do work very
odd hours especially now that i'm on
west coast most of my colleagues are on
east coast time
um so i do try mostly to wake up very
early and and stick to their schedule
but a lot of times it doesn't work out
um and that's fine i'm kind of a night
owl by nature anyway so um i will fire
off emails at what is going to be like 2
a.m eastern and what i do make sure to
communicate is that you know if i'm
sending an email at 2 a.m like it
doesn't mean i expect anyone to see or
respond or do anything with that email
at 2am um nor does it mean that i've
been working from like 9am eastern to
2am eastern like it's just
you know the async
i think i mean that's really the future
of most work environments for data
science i would suppose i think someone
like chris heard on twitter probably has
stronger words than i do about that but
which which i would recommend as a
follow for um uh
remote work hot takes but um yeah i mean
it's just it's really comes out of
communication i let people know if i'm
traveling and you know blocking time on
my calendar things like that um
because some afternoons i do we do need
to move or make it make a drive or
something like that and you know i just
i just set it as busy and then people
know that i'm not there um and just let
them know
thanks yeah i think i think blocking
calendars is the the key right
because that says you know don't expect
an answer in this three period three
hour period or whatever
yep for sure
i like that point though about you might
answer at two but that doesn't mean
you're expecting somebody to answer you
right away too
it's when people answer back and you get
into a conversation yeah
i know katie from our team used to put
something in her email signature like i
send emails at off times but that
doesn't mean i expect a response
oh that's great i love that oh i think
sam i think you just actually shared
that in the chat too
yeah that was we used that um
tagline a lot of my last job in fact our
president had it on his email i'm
working a remote schedule
i know i don't expect an answer back and
i'm flexible
um
like to your comment i have the same
situation so when i lived in bermuda
you had a choice you either got bermuda
holidays or you got a us holidays and
every employee made a choice and and
they are different
um and the key is just like
to let everybody you know you just had
to communicate people hey this is your
holiday i know it and you know this is
my holiday and you know work around it
and
fortunately
it's the oddballs where you run into
trouble like like i would say like today
the jubilee is going on and we just had
memorial day in the united states but
the summers tend to be okay and like
in bermuda they had
um cricket holiday on august 1st and 2nd
the entire island shut down for two days
so the north could play the south in
cricket um and you know that was one of
the things it's like an odd odd days but
it's the summer so so
it's not as bad but it's just really
about communications and expectations
you just got to set them
and expect people to live by them
really i am i see robert you had a
question
in the chat you want to ask live
sure yeah um
on async work like
i guess being productive with others
especially when conversations get
complex maybe there is no
good tool other than a meeting or a call
like email versus slack versus mirror
like are there any async tools that you
like to actually work through something
complicated and make decisions uh
without the without the meeting
such a good i'd love to learn from
others on this one myself um i will say
what what we do i mean we try to lean
into github whenever we can you know i
think the process of writing down
where you're stuck um and
you know like here here's my replex or
what i'm doing
how do we solve it like that's good when
working with non-technical i mean like
you know non-data scientist um you're
right sometimes you just gotta re resort
to the meeting and that's and that's
fine uh it's it can be a lot more
efficient that way but
um the the drawback there is you don't
end up documenting i think a lot of us
have learned
in the last couple years with the remote
setups that really just writing things
down reduces those institutional
knowledge silos where you can never pick
up if someone leaves and go somewhere
else and you go oh my god we don't know
how to do this anymore um
instead of the meetings whenever
possible writing things down is really
wise as far as tooling
another one i wish i had a good answer
for like oh we used this consolidated
approach with this thing but now we're
kind of spattered all over the place we
have some slack some teams some github
emails um yeah i don't know because i
you know i was um interacting with
someone on twitter recently.loom and
that looks awesome to sort of share it
so loom as a platform for sharing quick
little videos um screen shares with like
i think it has like a little head shot
of you talking in it or something like
that
and it seems like a really great
solution for asking and answering
technical questions in a streamlined way
but i have not used it myself curious if
others have recommendations there
hannah i see you said loom is great i
love to hear what that is
yeah so i've used it before for async
work especially with project kickoffs
when you can set context really easily
with a short video you can reduce
meetings get everyone on the same page
and then have everyone kind of digest
all the information before you meet for
more technical work so i found that's
really important whenever you're kicking
off
projects
also for
updates that you maybe would have a
weekly sink on sometimes you can just do
it in four minutes over a loom video and
then if there are any follow-up
questions
someone could send you a loom video
right back
i love it yeah
does anyone else have other tools that
have been useful
i see a few
being shared in the chat right now too
[Music]
oh slack does the video messages i see
maddie said that's awesome i didn't know
that
alexander i see you asked the question
um
well as we're sticking on this remote
work topic right now do you want to want
to jump
in uh hi yeah um travis thanks for
speaking with us today um i wanted to
ask you about um
your ability to work remotely so is this
something that you've always done or is
it something that became possible
because of the pandemic
and i'm also wondering you know i hear i
always hear a lot about how
there's a lot of new roles that are
opening that are remote but i'm still
curious is this like are people hiring
um with remote roles in mind for data
science or
is this still something that needs to be
like negotiated
um
like pretty intensely in order to have
because i know there's a lot of talk now
about return to work and
um a lot of ceos are saying people need
to come back so i'm just curious um how
this became possible for you and if you
have any insight into what it may be
looks like now in the market
yeah sure um so for like a couple things
there that awesome question i love it
the turn to work phrase is like usually
a hot button um phrase with
huge remote proponents um so it implies
sort of that we weren't working before
yeah like when we are in the office um i
know that's not what you meant but um
but it's just sort of a funny thing that
it struck me um but yeah i think if it
in in the negotiation stage which you
mentioned um so if you're looking at a
role and and it turns into
a company or an org saying well we're
gonna let you work remote um as if it's
some sort of privilege it could be a red
flag if remote really is your intention
and and your desired mode of working and
if you work well that way
it's just the way you work i mean i
don't think it's it's it's a privilege
or not it's just it's
the way that you're productive and if
and if orgs don't see it that way then
maybe that's a that's kind of an early
indicator um
it's an important conversation to have
early on you know like when we're
interviewing new people for for our team
we make sure to say like our org is 100
remote um and indeed for us and even for
me the 100 remote like going away remote
only became possible because of the
pandemic
so kind of one of the few bright points
of the pandemic it allowed us to say we
really can do this from anywhere at any
time
um but now that we've done that and it's
successful and there are of course cost
benefits to not having brick and mortar
or all those things it makes sense for
us so we say like you know our intention
is to stay 100 remote and that's what
this role is and then there's no there's
no kind of like we're gifting you this
this benefit um it is just the way it is
um because people are i mean a lot of
stuff exactly are showing that people
even became more productive when they
work remotely which makes a lot of sense
to me i know i did too i don't waste two
hours a day sitting in a car and you
know
putting on proper pants or whatever the
the case may be yeah
yeah i definitely um i'm sorry i
definitely meant return to uh return to
office not returning yeah i know yeah
yeah no no no i i i didn't i didn't mean
to sound accused no
i know exactly what you meant i didn't i
didn't sense any like ill will
um yeah but i definitely think you're
right i think that this pandemic has
definitely shown that there are some
things for data scientists that are just
i don't i've personally found easier to
do at home than in the office um and i
think this conversation we're having
today is really bringing up important
points about maybe some of the
challenges with remote work
um i know we're talking about loom and
how that can be really helpful i find
another thing that still maybe i find
more helpful in the office is
brainstorming and the main reason is
because of whiteboarding
it's really hard to whiteboard over zoom
and like brainstorm those ideas um so
thanks for having this conversation and
for sharing um your insights
yeah sure yeah thanks for the questions
i see there's an anonymous question that
came in a bit earlier which is shifting
gears a little bit um but in simple
terms what is the difference between
early phase and late stage clinical
trials what's the difference in the work
there
oh yeah um sorry if i i started if i
started with jargon um this whole thing
that was not what i meant to do um so
the
um clinical trials as a whole uh you
have phase one two three and sometimes
four so phase one and two are kind of
early investigational studies where
you're looking at a new drug and you
wanna know is it safe and do we have any
hints that it's going to be effective
for a particular disease or patient
population and then later stage trials
um
phase stage
um
the the three four um so three is the
the the classic randomized controlled
trial where where you're saying we
believe it's safe we believe it's
effective let's prove it
and then f4 is usually a very large
population wide um
you kind of surveil the the you know
like lots of people are taking statins
these days
you could run a phase for us and like a
statin and make sure that it's doing
what it's supposed to do and that it's
still safe and in
larger populations sometimes even harder
to reach
um aspects of the population that might
not have enrolled in in the classic
phase three rct um
and then
i i was i was referring to late stage
prostate cancer prostate cancer is a
disease in which
a lot of men are diagnosed very early on
so an early stage of disease
and the the kind of actions you would
take clinically for
early stage prostate cancer very
different than those you take for late
stage prostate cancer which is most
often metastasized to the bone or other
places so we mostly operate in the in
the late stage phase with metastatic
disease um kind of low life expectancy
and a real opportune time to introduce
new drugs that are helpful
thank you travis that's really helpful
sure
um a few other
questions in the chat coming in right
now too and um i see sam you asked one
and you put a little star for me to read
it so a reminder if you
maybe are somewhere that's a bit loud or
you want me to read a question feel free
to put a star next to it in the chat too
but it was how do you convince
leadership in pharma companies that are
still hesitant or resistant toward
remote work that it's the future for
data science
oh that's like the million dollar
question i guess i um
i suppose i've been fortunate not to be
in that role i've had to make that i've
not been in position i've had to make
that argument myself um so
i'm gonna i'm gonna cast and i don't
know in into the
um into the chat uh if anyone has
suggestions i'm really interested to
hear them i read a lot of blogs and a
lot of kind of like twitter takes on
this um
and you know like some of the hot takes
are just sort of like well i'll leave
you know we'll all leave and go get
remote jobs that make more money and i
mean like sure um but if you like the
work you're doing in the place you're
you're working that's probably not the
best solution if you'd like to you know
have a civil
productive conversation i
have anyone had to make this case or
want to
yeah be great if someone yeah someone
has a suggestion or experience so in um
in my experience
kind of in a previous role
um we did have a group that were working
together
um
in one location
and
in that sense we there were certain
individuals this is pre-pandemic but
certain individuals can in order to get
work-life balance and write and you know
kind of
get that in place where they were having
to commute a fair distance
and get take kids to school and so their
their work day was kind of
difficult because of all of that they
they were trying to make the point that
perhaps it would be more productive for
them to be at home certain days in the
week so that they could then you know
get the kids off to school do a full
day's work go back pick them up and deal
with everything
the
line manager at the time was kind of
saying well because
they wanted to keep a cohesive group
present
in that location
if individuals were kind of off working
in remote locations that was harder
i can kind of understand that rationale
just in terms of a group dynamic and the
kind of
um
over the coffee
pot you know around the kettle kind of
discussions that you occasionally have
with colleagues or you know you just
turn around in your chair and ask
questions that's much harder when
everyone's remote
so i kind of understood that
um point of view
um i think
well just
before the pandemic i made the case to
to work remote and you know my manager
at the time was like sure you know
you're you're on the phone
ninety percent of the time to focus on
remote locations so why should it matter
where you work
um
and then the pandemic happened and
as far as i'm can as far as i'm aware i
don't think that productivity has
markedly dropped
within my organization
uh in the last two years so i think it's
a much stronger lever now to say hey
look we can do this remotely
um
sure there are some jobs that are more
tricky or certain circumstances that are
you know maybe you need to have closer
interactions with colleagues like if
someone is brand new into the industry
from
graduating you know you maybe want to
have closer interactions with them to
make sure that they're getting it and
they're not kind of
um you know
veering off the path too much let's
let's call it that um
but i i honestly think that once you
kind of get to
a level of knowing what you're doing in
your job
i can't see why anyone
could have a strong argument that you
have to be in the office
that's a that's a great
i i love that story um in that you're
pushing for a pre-pandemic and i think
for a lot of places the pandemic
just was the proof that said look we
really can do this and like what you
know
it's it's
it's almost like the the onus is now on
the the in office people like will show
me how
productivity increases when we're in the
office because we've we've we've proved
it like in in the most
dire circumstance like in a time
when we shouldn't have been productive
um i mean that that's the thing the the
coveted enforced remote style of remote
work is not normal remote work that's
not the way that it's supposed to be
it's supposed to be more of a choice and
uh you know an intentional thought
process than rather than an emergency
knee-jerk reaction um so that we did so
many companies that so well remotely in
in the worst of situations means that
they will do even better in normal times
i mean i i have to say that i think
communication is much more difficult
you know you have to be intentional
about communication
um
and also i think that uh
it's easy for individuals to feel
isolated
you know and that's that's got a
knock-on effect on mental health and
everything else so you know it i there
are pros and cons for sure
but um you know i think having those
honest discussions about them is is a
good first step
yeah totally agree i something i meant
to mention about remote work in general
i learned a lot from um the get lab
suite of resources they have so much out
there and they have a really good
coursera course um i think it's called
remote team management or something like
this
um which is very good and then they have
a
remote team handbook which speaks to a
lot of those topics you know how do we
they always say the biggest you know
challenge is communication and you know
document everything but that's really
hard and how do you carve time for it
and make sure it's done and how do we
balance just kind of connectedness in
the long run certainly things to think
about and be intentional though
oh i saw it information yeah that's the
one protein management yeah that's the
right one okay yeah
thank you
um i know
on this topic as well ethan you just put
a comment and question around like
staying connected to your co-workers do
you want to jump in and add some context
yeah i was just wondering kind of what
um
mike mentioned i think about people
feeling more isolated i know i've felt
much more isolated um i've i've worked
now at two companies
neither of which was big on remote
before the pandemic
and
maybe
haven't put a lot of thought into like
doing remote well they've
one of them the one i'm with now hired
me on fully remote which is wonderful
um
but um i definitely missed more of the
interactions with co-workers in person
um
but they're all in ohio i'm in
mississippi so we can't like just meet
up
um and i'm just wondering what uh
other people have seen
that has worked for helping you stay
connected
oh go ahead oh no you go ahead
i was wondering if any of you work at
the companies that have done the the um
the remote like if you're a fully remote
company something that's become uh hip
maybe these days is like the
retreat sort of idea where you just go
like a place in the country or somewhere
else and just go um we haven't done that
at our org we've talked about it a
couple times but i'm curious if anyone's
done that and if it was awesome
yeah i see a few hands raised if you
have
maybe suggestions or ideas for for this
question
um harsh i saw your hand raise first you
want to jump in
actually i want to say like a remote job
is good i completely agree with mike
also because i have done remote job also
and work from office so both experience
i am having
when i was a fresher pass out from the
college then the remote job was quite
very complicated i will be honest
because i don't have any experience how
the iit industry work or what is the
domain they are working so in sitting in
an isolated room and in the front of
computer for nine hours it's like become
frustrating your line unit is telling
you like do this by that way like that
is quite fast for a beginner in the
industry but in the office environment
the most important i think i love is
that interaction with the people you are
hanging out you're working if you have a
problem then you are right referring hey
how do you do that he will tell you it's
so simple but in
remote because at present i am working
remote
as well as office my team is liking
three or four nations australia uk
budhavi in india like my 11 team members
are divided into the four nation so we
are handling the project
of stock market domain so
the interaction is quite good but
sometimes it's quite complicated also
because uh first of all
the language barrier is not there but
pronunciation barrier comes around how
you're understanding your mate like
because you don't see their facial
expression you are just hearing your
voice you have never met them and like
so i would suggest that working from
office is much and much easier and
interactive funny and like nine to six
hour my work time goes like
so fast that i can't believe that and
nine to six hour in the front of laptop
in my home is like a 24 hour job it
looks like
but for a fancy person i do feel you're
yeah
i i hear you on sometimes it's hard to
know like someone's sense of humor or
when you're just like slack messaging
with them but um thank you so much sam i
see you had your hand raised too if you
want to jump in
yeah um i actually a couple weeks ago i
got back from a retreat um with my
company we're fully remote we got about
40 to 50
um employees
and um
it was really fun uh there was a little
bit of work you know sort of during the
day but then um
you know like in the afternoon we like
did a scavenger hunt around the city and
um or we did uh i mean all sorts of just
silly little activities and they were
like you could go to this mall or you
can go you know to this museum or
whatever there were just all sorts of
fun activities and then the evenings of
course there were dinner and drinks and
everybody went out after the dinner and
the drinks and had more drinks and
so it was a very fun uh very fun time
and it was really fun getting to see
everybody
um but unfortunately it was a coved
super spreader event
oh jeez
but i was boosted so i'm i'm good but
yeah
it was fun
i would i would love to chat more about
it offline if anybody is interested
yeah that's really cool sounds great
minus the covent part yeah exactly yeah
yeah
yeah i saw someone actually mention
something that i also um do from time to
time where
there's this um
you can co-work with your you know like
in a zoom or any kind of um team's
meeting
even silently um especially with the
onboarding process i find that's really
helpful so that the person
or people know that i'm there and
available um like i have things to do so
i mean i'll just
sometimes even turn off our camera and
just like go on mute and then you know
if you want to like pop on and say oh i
got this thing i'm stuck i got a
question um it works really well you can
block an hour or two
with with um certain colleagues do that
from time to time it's kind of like
working side by side
that's a good idea
um
okay there's a few other questions that
are on slido anonymously that are on a
different topic and one was
does python have as big of a place as r
and clinical trials
i've i haven't seen it yet um i could be
totally blindsided by something that i'm
just not aware of um but i think the
reason is that r was traditionally built
and is more maintained in the classical
statistical space
and there's not too much nlai which of
course is a python strong point um going
on in the traditional clinical trial
world so um just the strength in terms
of you're going to run a regression or a
survival analysis and you're going to
get exactly what you're going to get you
know it's correct um i think
it's
sort of accepted as a more
as a truth um compared to python and
this is not a slight towards python um
like it just i just think it's the
different way that these languages have
evolved
thank you
um
trying to go through a few other
questions i saw from earlier i think
javier you asked a question around um
like commenting in your code would you
want to jump in and
ask that one yeah i i don't know if i'm
unique to this because
now with um bloom reach the company i'm
working at now you know our team is much
smaller so
over the last few years i don't know if
it's covered related or not but i have
been putting
you know a lot less
comments in my code um i think part of
that too is like our teams have just
sort of matured
so
there's less of a need to comment stuff
that you know
is like
clearly obvious what's going on you know
um
do you have any advice for like when to
draw the line of
i should comment or put some pros in my
code here or not
um
the
so i i'm guilty of this um i've
definitely written like some code
especially when i so i i started the
data science team um that i've been
leading now at this org so when it when
when it was initiated it was just me
like writing a ton of code and um i
didn't always comment that well which
was not wise for future me and certainly
not wise for um other people that would
be joining the team
um what's what's been helpful
is um
i work for example with um shannon
pallegi who's awesome at
communicating with me
uh this was hard to read um so i like i
i honestly lean on others to tell me
what that line should be um it's
something that i think it was allison
hill might have mentioned they were
taught me about this which is like a
almost like a feelings journal for for
how you're experiencing a set of code
like when you open up the our document
if you just kept like an informal side
document which is
when i saw this line i felt um
happy
because it was well commented or i felt
like what is going on um like those
sorts of things feedback from colleagues
when they're you know you do paired
programming or code review is really
really helpful to me to know like
something that might be
clear to me because i've written the
statement a million times is like not
super clear without a comment
that that helps thanks
sure
i like that
feelings journal as you're going through
it
um brittany i i saw you had asked a
question in the chat earlier as well do
you want to jump in
yeah i think for a lot of us who have
had the more traditional in-office
environment um and with remote work
becoming more
popular you kind of get a grass is
greener on the other side kind of
feeling and you're thinking maybe i do
want to go fully remote so i think i'd
just like to ask the group what are
maybe some pros that we should consider
but also some maybe downsides or cons
that someone should also consider before
thinking about that switch from
being maybe partially remote or fully in
office to being fully remote
a quick take from me um would be
a couple
i mean the benefits to me are
such that i'm i'm here um so
i'm clearly a biased observer here but
um
of course some of the challenges we've
talked about are the communication and
maybe potential isolation i mean that
that really is something that
you the the team has to be so so
thoughtful about to make it work well
and make sure everyone's still engaged
and feels like they're part of something
it's meaningful and that everyone's
growing um that's that's something i
really try to keep tabs on
in the team that everyone you know like
did you learn something this week or you
know how do you feel about your future
and like next week and and not because
it's it's very easy i think in this
potentially isolating environment to to
just have like be in the grind of like
producing the thing like you know oh you
did your tables this week great like
let's move on and we'll do more tables
next week or whatever the case may be
i'm just checking in about
people um and making sure that they're
balanced and happy is
something if it's possible to probe
early on like what if you can get a vibe
um
i'm sorry that there's not a more
rigorous thing to look for than that but
um that would be my two cents
thank you
um sam i see you have your hand raised
to add on to this too
yeah so
i when i first switched to remote work i
was working um for the federal
government and
um
i hated it at first um because you know
i had this nice little commute on the
metro and i would you know and do out
you know go out to drinks and everything
afterwards you know so i would so i
hated hate and hated working from home
um but now i love it and i won't ever do
a job that's not working for home again
i think my biggest piece of advice if
you are looking to switch to fully
remote work is to definitely get your
like a work space like a total and
that's what you do in that space as you
work because when i first started
working
my
workspace was also in my bedroom and
that was just like such a bad vibe
generally
um so yeah definitely if you want to
make the switch make sure you have a
dedicated and it doesn't have to be like
a whole room like i happen to have an
office right now but i think if as long
as you have like a desk or something
that's like a dedicated workspace i
think that's really important
totally endorse that one too yeah
sometimes when the weather's bad like i
feel that when i work in my room like in
the rv which is you can imagine it's
actually pretty small um that that feels
very crushing um like soul crushing so i
have a tent
that i work in when the weather's not
great um and i have like a little space
heater that i'll put in and things like
that and even just that simple walk from
my rv to the tent is like okay i'm going
to work now um
and so yeah i completely agree the
dedicated workspace is huge
i agree as well
i had to move my desk out of my bedroom
that was just too much and once he went
space
um
i see eric you had a question earlier on
commenting code do you want to jump in
yeah definitely um so
i've my covers have been saying in the
chat thinking a future year was quite
important when you're commenting on code
and the like but i'm one effort i did
earlier this year
is it's not just about the code for a
specific project it's how you're
accessing certain environments or maybe
using reusable you know code across
projects or just other
kind of intangibles i'm just curious how
your team is approaching how you
document and share your learning about
you know how you're accessing certain
tools in your infrastructure or how
you're trying out new you know ways of
doing analysis and how you're sharing
that learning across so that nobody's
like trying to do it all themselves
every time
and trying to avoid that syndrome
yeah that's such an awesome question and
something that i that i worried about
not on this role but in my at my last
work too how do we create like a wiki
that is just
suppose you landed in like a data
scientist role here tomorrow like how
would you know like what to do where are
the keys what are the what are you doing
like um
and i
i
something i pursued in the past was like
um github pages via netlift so making
just like a simple like our markdown
site um
and and putting that together the the
limitation that i found there was then
the the people who can
contribute knowledge to those pages are
only those who know our markdown um and
and that's big because i want people who
don't code to feel like they can come
and comment on our processes and um and
and share their knowledge as well um so
these days um as as much as i'm
reluctant to say it among the data
science crowd we're just using like
sharepoint um like which is fine it's
easy it's lightweight like
you know it's kind of already licensed
through org so it was free um but other
suggestions i mean any other thing that
people are using there would be i'd love
to learn about that as well just what's
in what's a low
barrier to entry wikipedia knowledge
base kind of tool kit i i haven't
stumbled on my favorite
i can tell you that what i did earlier
this year is i did do an r markdown
based site with blog down but i found a
theme where
most of the content is just marked down
itself it's not like i'm doing our
specific
markdown syntax and i was able to tie it
with github actions so that somebody
could go on a page they would see a
button that says edit this page if they
see something wrong or seen an
improvement it would take them straight
to github and or org for that page they
could just edit it on the spot in github
itself and then put the poll request
i merge it in then there's a github
action that redeploys it
um that's very cool yeah it took a lot
of work to get there because
infrastructure at big orgs is always a
complicated mess sometimes but once i
got a little you know help from rit
group on
setting up the deployment piece i'm much
happier with this solution than what i
was doing in the past which was in
essence scattered files on a shared
linux like file system space that nobody
could index or find or anything like
that so it's been helping future me at
least
i see there's a few comments in the chat
of tools people are using to do
we recently moved over to confluence
like very recently
but i still do find myself like
searching slack to find help
full links and stuff too and
i
it's just a habit of mine
you find the experience with confluence
good like i i've because i know i tried
like
i tried it and and i felt like it was
hard um even as a defense like it felt
very developer friendly and unless like
real people is that your experience or
is it hasn't improved i mean that was
years ago well when i say we just moved
over it was like a week ago
so
really sure yet but i will let you know
cool okay
um i see raha you asked a question
around code reviews too do you want to
jump in
yeah sure so right now in my group the
only person coding is really me
but i'm going to start with a i'm hiring
a postdoc and then we're going to bring
on a bunch of undergrads and i would
like to
i would like some sort of mutually
beneficial relationship where i can give
input on how their coach could be
structured better but i also need to
have them look at mine and all of the
things i didn't comment that i should
have and i don't know what the best way
to implement this would be also taking
into account that for some people their
code might be
like it's they might think of it as
their property like they don't want to
give it away to another student who
would just recreate what they've done um
so i want to protect them but also make
them better
yeah that's a good question so this is
um garrick i think i see garrick hey you
taught me about this um like pair
programming strategies um
something that i found is
is hard for me is when someone says can
you review my code and then it's like
points me to a github repo and then i
don't know where to start and it feels
like a lot
instead um pair programming strategies
whereby maybe one that that garrick was
teaching about is a driver passenger
sort of setup where someone codes and
someone else is kind of like the
passenger and saying what are you
thinking now like what are you doing
next um and then you kind of
iterate together through through the
code base in real time as you develop it
potentially so it's it's less a review
like mortem um and more of a like how do
we how do we think through and build and
that's really good for um
onboarding people too um but then that
could also work for simple code review
if it's already done um just kind of
like looking block by block you know
like have maybe the the person who wrote
the code could be the the driver then
and then they go okay here's the first
thing i was gonna do i open this file
and then i was gonna
load this data and here's my thought
process and and then it kind of i think
it really speeds up the the workflow
instead of just like feeling lost when
you land in a big code base which is
usually my experience
thank you i i see a few um comments in
the chat around pair programming
too and
britney so you just asked the follow-up
question there too if you want to jump
in
yeah so i have the pleasure of being
probably one of the very few like
handful maybe two handfuls of people on
my like 80 90 person team who uses r
and so i noticed one of the challenges
is if i wanted to do pair programming
with someone
um a lot of people actually don't know
the language so i don't know if it's
just you have to find someone else who
knows it and try to do it only with them
or if anybody has tips around what to do
in that scenario
that was actually how we stumbled on
pair programming originally um garrick
and i was that we were trying to onboard
people who did not know r um so it
certainly can work there and you're
right it kind of limits like you sort of
in many cases need to be the driver if
the person doesn't know any r whatsoever
but it can be valuable for for kind of
um
more entry-level tasks if if that the
you know
the
learner is then the driver and then you
you know make clear that we have all the
time in the world here like it's okay to
not know what to do next and just you
know like lean on me when you need it um
that that works too oh gary okay do you
have other thoughts you've done this
more than me so i feel like i'm just
trying to channel you
yeah i mean just talk about pair
programming i will appear
this is awesome
yeah i um i love it i think one of them
one of my favorite parts about pair
programming and especially like if you
have someone who's newer to a codebase
or newer to programming be the driver so
they're the ones actually like typing
and moving the mouse and everything um
and then the person who knows more is
the person uh
i don't know what the right words are so
maybe driver and password but like
so there's like a backseat driver is the
person who knows more and they're kind
of saying like okay now you know go over
here go into this file click this thing
and um
and what i found is like it really
forces you to slow down and explain at a
level that is that is that matches the
person who is um who's learning and like
it can be really easy to just sort of
like you know like be really easy to
just like brain dump to be like hey
let's have a meeting like here's how
everything works and like you don't
realize it's like it's too much you're
overloading it's it's going too quickly
you know they don't have the right
context et cetera but um but actually
sort of moving through
the the code together and doing smaller
tasks like you realize you can you get a
sense for you know what's the right pace
um by doing that and that's one of my
my favorite parts of it
awesome thank you
um i see zach you had some thoughts on
this too if you want to jump in
or i can read i can ruin yours nope
happy to um i was going to throw the
video um
but uh i guess uh
i found it that
we
we schedule some time for
basically everyone to be like the driver
um and then have people kind of
ask clarifying questions or
you know how did you approach this
um
and i always think uh
yeah it's just kind of a fun activity
um i would agree with uh lizzy that it's
it just like brings a different
perspective to
the way that you approach code um
yeah
cool
that's great thank you any other
thoughts on this topic before i shift
gears
and i realize an hour is going by very
quickly
there was a a great question on slido
asked anonymously that was when trying
to start a data science department in a
medium company
what would you
say are some points to take into account
like also are there any guidelines or
books to check out
um i always recommend emily robinson and
jacqueline knowles book um becoming a
data is that what it's called becoming a
data scientist um
from manning publishing it's awesome
awesome um i read that when i wasn't
looking for a job and i wasn't even
building a car i just devoured it
because it was just so good and then i
find that i often return to it as i do
new things when i look for new roles
when i build a department there's lots
of good examples in there about big orgs
small orgs what to expect i i do recall
that there is a particular section in
there where they they interview someone
who um
has started a uh biblical data science
things um uh who has started
a a data science division in an existing
kind of smallish medium-sized org um and
i would point to that that'll probably
cover it more completely than i could
that i could try to hear
um
yeah i don't know yeah that i'll
probably did that um i don't want to
like say something that is not as good
as the book you should just go read the
book
i will say i need to go read that book
too because it is one of the most
recommended resources at this hangout
it's so good yeah
awesome yeah and i know a few people or
eric shared the podcast too which is
really great as well
oh yeah for sure
awesome
i want to make sure i haven't missed any
questions through the chat sometimes i
know it's hard when there's a lot of
comments but i love all the comments and
conversation that happens in the chat
feel free to raise your hand if you had
asked a question earlier and i
unfortunately missed it
can i unmute and ask a question yeah um
i think i asked a question that several
other people also like chimed in and
asked a different version of which was
you know talking about your experience
of being the only or the first data
scientist
and growing a team from there
i know that i have been avoiding roles
where someone's like you would be the
only data scientist and you know
that's a scary thing to think about how
did you approach that
yeah um
in hindsight you know i kind of like won
the lottery with regards to the org that
i'm in um so the ceo who i report to is
so supportive of like
we know data science is our need in our
next direction and so
um i was kind of given just like a lot
of green room to run um
if you're toying with the idea i would
suggest making sure that's that that
that's the case um in larger orgs where
maybe you don't have as close contact
with you know
leaders
leadership that would make executive
decisions around how much to invest
whether it's in people or in tooling
sometimes the people actually most often
are always the people are more important
than the tooling
and data scientists aren't cheap so
making sure that if you're going to
build a data science team that that
everybody's like full you know going
into with eyes might open that
this is an investment and it's
absolutely going to return the value um
but but brace yourself um
so i mean that's just just getting
making sure the buy-in is already there
rather than i think going into it and
thinking the the
we're going to change the philosophy
here i think i think that's a much much
harder thing to do if you get the sense
that
maybe they're just they're kind of happy
enough with with like the the kind of
excel kingdom
and maybe they want to toy with the idea
of like let's tinker with some data
science and like everybody's got a data
scientist these days let's get one of
those that that might be kind of a
warning signal
yeah
awesome i appreciate it
sure
i love all the questions and energy
this week i see eric you just asked
a question in the chat too you want to
jump in
yeah um so going back to kind of your
work in the clinical space with our i'm
just curious from your perspective
travis what are some of the
kind of trends you're seeing and how r
is being used and some more you might
say innovative work in this space i'm
certainly seeing some i'd love to hear
your perspective on areas that you think
are becoming quite hot in this in this
space for doing some outside the box
ideas or more innovative analyses
i i love so yeah that's an awesome
question and i love the um kind of back
to basics trend across all of data
science so like the
[Music]
sequel first tools being the new hotness
that is actually the old hotness um
and uh i think our the way you know tidy
verse and d plier things like data
manipulation and and those
environments are written is so readable
and um
i i think that
the move away from things like sas i'm
saying isn't readable it's it's very
evil for some people um but but i think
i'll go ahead and you know like put in
my opinion that d player is more
readable and i think it's and gear cause
often we've often pondered this together
we'll go
i wonder what would be the error rate if
someone's just written strict sass like
doing the same task someone who's very
fluent in sass when it was very fluent
in deep player writing and code
reviewing these two things um
how how error-prone like what would
their rate be in both scenarios like
some sort of a b test with these two
sorts of languages um and again i'm not
trying to get into language or here it's
not really about that but i think there
are licensing advantages to moving away
from sas and and if if we get
readability advantages less error-prone
code
more translation into sql based
variations where we can leverage tools
like dbt which i know was on a previous
hangout there's a little bit discussion
about that um for better data
documentation better data cataloging um
i think we'll understand our sources
better and in the end for us in life
sciences that's going to translate to
better patient impacts because we're
producing higher quality
reports on higher quality data we've
definitely seen with our markdown we
produce things for safety monitoring
boards where they go oh my goodness like
you just sent us this html document or
this you know pdf thing that is so
elegantly readable um that in the past
when i received one from some other you
know software vendor or whatever the
case may be it was very hard for me to
see that i need to be worried about this
particular patient or this particular
outcome in this cohorts because it's
just kind of masked a bunch of like
ascii
nastiness um but then now that we can
produce really elegant our markdown sort
of documents or quarto as it may be
these days i think we're going to see a
lot of good impacts in the life sciences
space so that's that's what i'm thinking
about it's kind of like no ml no ai no
big data it's just regular old counting
things and making good looking tables
and figures um i think we're getting
really good at that
yeah i couldn't agree more on the
interactive results that we could
present that yeah shiny of course is a
part of that but also like you said we
can do our markdown static html but with
interactive elements and i think it's
just getting
some of these legacy processes to be
aware that there is this new world out
there where i don't have to give you a
hundred page rtf output i can give you
something with the dt table and plotly
to quickly drill down on those patients
and maybe a safety physician wants to
look at so really enjoy those insights
there
cool
i know we're a minute over the top of
the hour do you have
[Music]
a few more minutes you have to run
i could
i think i have to run
okay i'm sorry
oh yeah no i just i know my next meeting
starts at five after i i have four
minutes to give i'm i'm quite happy to
give them
okay
awesome um
there was one um slido question that
just came in was thank you so much for
doing this what are your actual
practices for making code handoffs as
painless as possible
um
that's an iterative answer i think
learning like when i handed off
something last time how awful was the
experience for the person who received
my code um i always try to ask that
question and
um i always get an answer that there was
a pain point so
like it's not something i can solve once
and for all but but i'm definitely still
learning um these days like when i wrote
that map function it was real ugly and
it was not clear what it was doing
um something like that so
just just asking people who see your
code how they felt the feelings journal
i love this idea the field journal of
reading code yeah
love that
um there is a conversation happening now
around like devops and data engineering
in the chat and i don't want to
cut that short so i want to let you know
travis it's okay for you to go to your
meeting so i just want to say thank you
so much for for joining us and sharing
your experience this has been awesome
of course yeah i'd love to hang out for
three minutes and see what the data
engine or the analytics engine are there
analytics engineering fans on here is
that is that a thing
um
it's our community thus far
awesome and uh yeah and travis while
we're talking about that i'm sure people
would love to know how to stay in touch
with you too if twitter is the best or
linkedin
you want to share that in the chat
oh sure thanks yeah i'll do that um it's
tr might well my username is
travisgerkey at both um i'll try to find
one and drop it in here so you can find
me there yeah probably twitter i check
more often but it feels like the future
of twitter is uncertain these days so
who knows um i try to hedge my bets with
linkedin and so here's my twitter um you
can even find me there
um yeah and honestly like
i try to
i i'm linked and i do this maybe more
than on twitter i update my location
fairly often and sometimes i've seen
people on my travels um like people in
our communities like recently we were in
missoula and we saw like
mara like i don't know anyone um
who's who's around if you're like oh
you're in the neighborhood like hit me
up and maybe i don't know like see real
people in real life and not be so
isolated so that's cool
it's great
um i see
robert who asked the question or started
off the conversation and chat had to
drop but the the point was starting data
science before devops and data
engineering is really difficult because
it puts the pressure on a data science
team to take some of these things on
and i know
libby you said you'd love to chat more
about this too and xavier you had some
thoughts so
feel free to jump in too
well we just
at least on my end we just implemented
uh
our studio team which feels like a huge
win for us
but we have a fairly small
you know group of professionals that i
would
classify as having you know data
engineering
skills or like the know-how
so i've had to get my hands dirty in a
lot of different ways that i wasn't
anticipating and i mean it's been good
for growth because i'm way more
comfortable in linux
and like
you know i
it sounds embarrassing but setting up
you know odbc connections setting up
drivers like things that i didn't think
i'd have to get involved with i'm
suddenly doing
um and it's been you know it's been
rewarding
but there are challenges because i
thought
you know i'd come into this new company
and
like you know week two i'd be crunching
out and deploying
apps or you know rmd reports and it just
hasn't gone that way i'm still very far
from
even productionizing like ml or ai
um in a meaningful way so
you know there it's it there's a lot of
baby steps that
i think
you know you you have to prepare
yourself for if you're
i just responded in the chat um i have
to jump off but but yeah i totally agree
and i don't have a good solution but i
love that you made the comment i hope
you all solve it and let me know next
time i joined
all right thanks again travis yeah sure
thank you
i know xavier just followed my
internet you're back you're back no clue
where i left off but
needless to say um
yeah i just think there's a lot of baby
steps you need to take like
to set up a proper
analytics engineering shop or data
science shop whatever you want to call
it
that's exactly where you left off so
that was perfect
so we heard we heard your whole point
too thank you
uh our studio has been super helpful
your team is amazing like tatsu your
software engineers i mean these people
have really gone out of their way
to help us troubleshoot you know weird
nuances so thank you
that's awesome to hear thank you javier
um i know there are a few other
comments on this in the chat too so feel
free to raise your hand if you want to
jump in or just submit yourself
i'd put a comment about how in my
previous experience i um
took it upon myself to
prototype infrastructure for our studio
and shiny server and my org and it
definitely paid off where now we have
obviously the enterprise products but it
opened people's eyes and this is many
years ago like way way well i'm going
for art studio first came out
um and ethan was asking how did i get
started how did i get tasked with that i
literally took it upon myself i was one
of those where i'm maybe i'm too much of
a renegade in some areas of thought but
i saw the potential of what r could
bring in in our org and it had been used
a little bit before but
only by a handful of people and i
thought these
interfaces were enabling technology to
those that would be
interested in pursuing this with my
linux
kind of
side hobby of learning about linux and
doing that at home and running that
server on my own home server here i was
able to get a virtual machine from our
linux team i just said have at it just
don't break anything like yeah sure i
won't break anything and um sure enough
it took off so just had to get people
buying into
giving me the opportunity
and once i had the opportunity
it wasn't part of my day job by any
means like i wasn't hired to do
linux administration but i i knew enough
that if i could carve out a little bit
of time here and there
i could at least get this started and
now i have great help with it it's not
not me anymore but it does take somebody
to take that initiative and you kind of
have to make time for it and most of
these big orgs i would say but once you
do it the payoffs are tremendous i think
so
again it helped that i'm a linux geek at
heart so if it was um kind of in my
wheelhouse but
it's much easier now to learn about the
skills you need to do this than it was
back in my day to use a cliche
thanks so much eric
brittany i i see you said you were an
engineering analyst out of necessity not
your own choice but what has been
helpful for you and
in moving towards that
yeah i think just um
learning to collaborate
even across roles i think a lot of what
i had to do was collaborating with
people who are what you'd call
traditionally data engineers um but also
just
reaching out even beyond my company um i
think also realizing that you might find
yourself in this situation even if
you're in a larger company like i
mentioned earlier my team has 90
analysts alone
and i still found myself in the realm of
like having to figure out getting data
and cleaning it up and actual processes
for that so i think just like honestly
leaning into those opportunities is also
something i would highly recommend
because
i didn't realize i'd like it until i
started doing it so
thank you
yeah i
i think we have
covered all
the questions i
if there are certain things that we miss
feel free to raise your hand here too i
know travis is gone but all of you are
leaders here as well and
are qualified to answer some of these
questions
i know we covered a ton of stuff there
thank you all so much for for joining
today and for all the amazing questions
too
hopefully we'll see you all back next
week um have a great rest of the day
everybody
you